Не по своїй волі я захворів. Мене інфікували.
Були як сліпі кошенята, відверто кажучи, тому що ми не знали цієї проблеми.
Панацеї взагалі немає, тобто щеплення - це шанс. Шанс приборкати інфекцію.
Масочка чому не на носі? Масочка має бути на носі.
Це наша теж медичка працівниця. Все життя пропрацювала доктором на селі.
- Що в нас тільки не було.
- Все було, крім коронавірусу?
– Ну, був грип, жовтуха була, кір був, але такого чудовиська не було в нас. Ніколи. Я не знаю, що це таке. Я шокована.
Коли ми почули слово "ковід", "COVID -19", коли заговорили про пандемію, це автоматично було зрозуміло, що я як лікар-пульмонолог буду цим займатися.
Я пам’ятаю січень, березень, відверто кажучи, ми не сприймали це. Ну, були як сліпі кошенята, тому що ми не знали цієї проблеми,
не знали, як підійти до цієї проблеми, як вести пацієнта.
Це вже станом на нині ми, маючи маленький досвід, можемо бути в певних речах впевненими,
бо знаємо, як правильно розставляти пріоритети, як правильно пацієнта лікувати і рятувати пацієнта.
Такого показника захворюваності і такого показника смертності ніколи не було!
У мене був пік, коли лежало 49 хворих. 10 хворих виписую і 10 хворих поступає - і так через день.
Місяць роботи, всі були виснажені, але найважчий день - це тоді, коли ти ховаєш пацієнта. Це найважче, напевно.
Я з дозволу родичів записую на відео і відсилаю рідним на телефон для того, щоб рідні побачили
наживо і поспілкувалися зі своїм рідним, який лежить тут, як у тюрмі.
Я пам’ятаю, коли я зробив перший запис своєї пацієнтки, мати передавала вітання своїй доньці, побажання, що вона здорова,
говорила їй, що вона одужує, що вона поправиться.
Але так сталося, що через кілька годин після цієї розмови її просто посадили на апарат штучної вентиляції легень.
Вона, на жаль, померла. Але донька і рідні встигли побачити свою маму і почути останні слова. Розумієте?..
І пройшло вже декілька місяців… (плаче)
Вибачте. На той момент, коли я робив це відео, та й інші відео, завжди вагаюся, чи правильно я це роблю, чи потрібно, не потрібно?
У цій ситуації, коли вона мені через декілька місяців написала і просто подякувала, що вона згадала свою маму.
Я зрозумів для себе, що я на той момент зробив правильно. Скажу чесно, я всіх своїх пацієнтів пам’ятаю.
От вони в мене стоять перед очима, на жаль. Це складно, це боляче, але разом з тим життя продовжується,
і ти намагаєшся далі працювати і рятувати людей, от і все. Це… Це важко…
Рано чи пізно більшість людей перехворіє.
Питання в тому, хто перенесе в легкій формі, а хто буде мати важкий перебіг з якимись, не дай Боже, фатальними наслідками.
Панацеї взагалі немає, тобто щеплення - це шанс. Шанс приборкати інфекцію,
створити колективний імунітет і зменшити ризики, небажані ризики, в першу чергу фатальні.
Карантин потрібен, питання в тому, коли він має бути і наскільки він має бути суворий.
Ліжок усім вистачить, а от питання, чи вистачить усім кисню і чи вистачить медичних рук для того, щоб допомогти всім цим пацієнтам.
Відчуття нестачі повітря - це таке суб’єктивне відчуття, яке заводить пацієнта в паніку.
Яка призводить до ще більшого погіршення загального стану пацієнта. Пацієнт починає частіше дихати, це ще більше його виснажує і виникає порочне коло.
Коронавірус - це тригер, це як масло у вогонь. Вражаються не лише органи дихання, вражаються всі органи і системи.
Головне, щоб пацієнт довіряв, незважаючи на те, чи він лікар чи не лікар. Чи він медик чи не медик.
Якщо пацієнт довіряє лікарю, довіряє своє здоров'я. Коли лікар і пацієнт дивляться в одну сторону в контексті вирішення проблеми, тоді є успіх.
Мені всі говорили, що я півроку ходжу і я не захворюю. Нібито я безсмертний.
Я знав, що рано чи пізно це станеться. Це сталося несподівано. Враховуючи те, що моя родина була здорова,
слава Богу, я пішов на госпіталізацію й на самоізоляцію до себе в стаціонар з пневмонією.
Я поселився на робочому місці й далі продовжував лікувати своїх пацієнтів. Добре це чи погано? Хтось подумає, що дурень. Так і говорили. Але я не жалкую.
Принаймні в тій ситуації хоч був комусь корисний. Одна справа, ти дивишся очима лікаря чи очима медика.
А інша справа, коли ти дивишся під кутом зору пацієнта. По-іншому це все сприймаєш.
Це дало мені змогу побачити і вдосконалити роботу відділення. Такий собі маленький плюс.
Сатурація 98 у пацієнта на фоні кисню. Знімуть маску, сатурація впаде.
Для кожного важкого хворого в нас є додатковий ланцюжок на 4-5 метрів.
Пацієнт не має перерви в кисневій терапії, коли він, приміром, іде в душову кімнату. Це важливо.
Навіть кілька хвилин без кисню може закінчитися катастрофою, тому він постійно на кисні.
Завдяки коронавірусній інфекції ми побачили певні недоліки в системі охорони здоров’я, які треба вдосконалювати і виправляти.
У контексті призначення тих самих антибактеріальних препаратів. Антибіотики при COVID-19 не допомагають.
Антибіотики ми призначаємо лише в контексті виникнення вторинної коінфекції або вторинної бактеріальної інфекції
на фоні COVID-19.
Якщо би був відпуск тих самих антибіотиків за рецептурним бланком, було би зовсім все по-іншому.
І коронавірус також став певним індикатором людських стосунків.
От і все. З ким ти хочеш спілкуватися, а з ким краще триматися на відстані…
Ті, хто зараз зі мною працюють, наша команда - це класні хороші люди, вірні своїй справі, ідейні.
І питання не в грошах і не в якихось там меркантильних речах, а питання в стилі життя.
Дана ситуація з "ковідом" у світі - це якраз певний маркер,
який дає змогу перевірити, чи готова система охорони здоров’я взагалі до глобальних викликів.
Тобто - це виклик. Сьогодні - COVID-19. Ми ж не знаємо, завтра може бути щось інше.
Я одне що можу сказати, скажу чесно: на жаль, це надовго.
Людина - така істота, яка звикає до всього.
Ми навчилися з цим жити, ми повинні жити далі, тільки повинні жити далі правильно.
Як? Все банально і просто. Треба бути обережним і думати про ближнього.
Коли ти думаєш не лише про себе, а ще думаєш за інших, тоді менше проблем. Це стосується і COVID-19…